I heard everybody welcome back to
another YouTube hangout super excited to
be here again with you my last one of
the dates it's been a fun ride today I
have a special guest
I repeat guests we've got Alex back on
with me we had a great session before
Alec was talking about influencer
marketing and we had a fun session and
he runs his own podcast called the
influencer podcast and he wanted to have
me on as a guest on a show and I said
I'd love to Alex let's do it and hey why
don't we make it as a YouTube video
again so you guys could benefit and
learn a little bit more about Alex again
so it's gonna be simulcast it'll be live
here and he's gonna pull it for his on
his channel too so Alex before you do
your usual intro and all that can you
just quickly remind everybody again what
you're all about tell us about the
podcast and then the show is yours man
absolutely great to be on the show and
interviewing you at the same time so
I've i'm the founder of length fluency
which is now the world's largest online
training platform for linkedin as
recognized by huffington post's i
started the company with a mission to
change and transform how entrepreneurs
market themselves so that's a little bit
about our background we started the
influencer podcast because i've seen
that the direct power and i guess that
the benefits of building influence and i
think it is not it should it's an
absolute must for all entrepreneurs to
be able to learn and then build the
influence within their industry in order
to one stand out but to be able to
dominate their particular industry so we
started it to interview the world's best
to understand how they build their
influence so others can learn from them
and leverage their experience so that's
the influence of spod cast and obviously
we reached out to you because we believe
you built phenomenal influence within
your industry and from what I can see
you've built your influence a different
way than a few others that we've
interviewed so definitely think we're
going to get some great insidey all
right let's do it man I'm ready all
right beautiful so this will be
seven of the influences podcast and
today I'm joined by Evan Carmichael a
serial entrepreneur who by the age of 19
had achieved something that most 19 year
olds would not and I dare say most 30 40
year olds probably still haven't
achieved what he did and he sold a
software company then at the age of 22
he became a VC helping raise between
500k to 15 million so you know achieved
quite a lot at a young age and now he's
running Evan Carmichael dot-com which is
a very popular website for entrepreneurs
looking to learn and grow both within
themselves but also for their company so
he's a man on a mission who lives and
breeds you know entrepreneurship and he
is obsessed with his goal which I find
very very ambitious and exciting and
that's to help 1 billion entrepreneurs
you know grow and develop as within
themselves so Evan welcome to the show
it's great to be here Alex thanks for
having me you know growing up vii was
one of my lucky numbers because it
rhymes with Evan so I'm honored to be on
episode number 7 of your show here and
that was not pre-scripted we just
literally found that out so that's
awesome
yeah like I said like I've been obsessed
with influence and the topic of
influence and what builds influence and
I think a lot of people out there in the
market especially whether you start up
and you know that there's some people
listening to this show who are in their
40s and 50s and they don't know what
that means
so can you let's just start off with
before we kind of go into your story a
little bit more and uncover what built
your influence what does influence mean
to you and what does it mean to have it
I think influence is a really valuable
thing and also potentially scary thing
it's it makes you really powerful and
you have to decide how are you going to
use that power like like spider-man says
with great power comes great
responsibility and
fluence I believe is great power and and
what I see it as is the ability to to
help somebody down a path to guide them
on a path to have control over some of
the decisions that they make or maybe
you're making for them and so you know
the more influence you have hopefully
you know you're making decisions that
are in other people's best interests and
guiding them along their path if I
listened to you Alex and you give me
great advice on something and you know
you have you have a lot of credibility
and you have a lot of expertise and you
can we need to do this I'm going to
trust you because you have influence and
so that Trust is sacred and I'm going to
now take action based on what you told
me to do and to me that's what
influencer is all about absolutely I
agree and I think like I keep saying to
people whether you have influence or not
whatever article you put out whatever
posts you put out whatever video you put
out if it's not of the best quality and
if you know that you didn't do that with
100% of heart or you didn't do it with
100% responsibility that knowing
someone's going to read that and based
on you know whatever content you shared
they're going to make a decision now
that decision could completely change
their viewpoint about business or
particular direction they're heading and
if you don't if you're irresponsible
with your content and your influence
then you're actually doing people a
disservice so it's interesting you say
that because you know we all have a
responsibility to change people's lives
and I think that's the whole reason why
we're in business so yeah what was some
guess it leads me to the next question
what was the key strategy for you in
building your influence I know that you
have a big following on YouTube and
obviously your website Evan Carmichael
calm now so what was it for you take us
back to where it all started and then
what led you to where you are now where
it all started I think at the start of
every story is a lot of heart and you've
mentioned that word already a couple
times I had a business so you said when
I was 19 and I did not have a lot of
success with it at the start and I
to quit and it was among the worst days
of my life and you know I finally found
the way and made it through we can get
into that if you want to but the heart
for me was I didn't want other people to
have to struggle through the same
struggles that I went through through
the crazy lows of you know crying my
face off and just feeling totally
worthless I didn't want other people to
have to feel that and so I wanted to try
to share some of what I had learned to
help them get over those humps in the
early days of what I was doing there was
no business model it was just straight
up helping it was making YouTube videos
it was doing speaking engagements free
stuff taking meetings just trying to
help other entrepreneurs get better you
know when I sold my company I didn't
even know what I wanted to do yet it was
it was a great high like yeah I saw my
company is awesome and then also feel
like your kid just went off to college
or something like I didn't I had all
this time now and it is I lost my baby I
didn't know what to do and it's a good
problem to have I'm not complaining but
this is how I started spending my time
and saying okay well I want to help
other people get through those those
humps with hopefully not as much on the
on the downside because I almost quit
and that would have been that would have
been really bad for me if I if I quit
and so I know a lot of entrepreneurs who
do quit who do give up too soon don't
have the belief in themselves and so
that's the hard that's where that's
where it started for me and just seeing
people with potential who aren't living
up to their potential really really
fires me up really gets me upset it and
like I'm allergic to it and so I want to
I want to try to pull that out of people
and so I've executed it through
entrepreneurship since that's kind of
what I have some knowledge about also
and I think there's moments in our
career that put us on a map and on it
you know sometimes it's one big moment
that then leads to you know more greater
moments and then there's times where
it's a series of moments that really put
you on a map like I'm a big follower and
believe in what Gary Vaynerchuk preaches
and you know he said that there was one
talk that he did that really put him on
the map and got got things going for him
what was it for you was there a specific
moment was there a series of moments
where you thought one on building
influence into this is what I really
want to do for the rest of my life
yeah the moment it was a series of
moments but it all centered around
finding out what my one word is it's all
me it's the topic of my book sitting
here but I believe everybody has
something that they stand for you need
to figure out what that is before you
can start living a life and running the
businesses on purpose and so I was
having success but I couldn't really it
was hard to articulate what I did it was
hard people to spread my message it was
hard to really get a handle on what I
was all about for myself and so like I
can't even figure it out how is anybody
else gonna share it for me right you
know and you need word-of-mouth you need
people to spread your message as an
entrepreneur you you know I'm not taking
out Super Bowl commercials right so if
you can't even explain it then it's
gonna be hard for anybody else just
spread it for you
and so I went to this process and came
up with you know what I'm at my core all
about is belief I believe in people I
believe in their potential and I believe
in entrepreneurs specifically because
that's what I have a passion for and so
once I found that I thought I thought it
was actually too big an idea like oh
that's too like Who am I to be the
believed guy and such a big word so many
people have used it already like it's
too bull but so I needed to make it more
specific
and the more I kind of sat with it the
more I just I didn't like anything else
besides believe so I said you know what
I'm gonna try to do this crazy thing and
not just brand my business around
believe but but change my life around
believe and the execution would be
through my company as well the first
thing I did was May I made in my
newsletter I had a newsletter list and
my next newsletter was about belief and
that got a lot more traction my best
newsletter that I've ever put out and my
sister was the first one that replied
she said I really like your newsletter
actually read it now so thank you
Stephanie for that yeah that's that's
the ha moment when you see sisters that
are finally read your newsletter
actually like your stuff now it great
okay but you know sometimes it's
something only a sister can say to you
dude
I mean the next thing it was a video
around believe and I use the example in
my book where the the best video that I
had up to that point had a hundred
thousand views it took me a year to get
there and it was so proud of it like a
hundred thousand years it's such a great
video a lot of work went into it and it
took a year to get there and then I made
a video but believe in that video hit a
hundred thousand views in a month and
now has over million views and is
continued to do well and it's just like
this is it you know that this is what
I'm this is how I'm supposed to be
sending my message out to the world and
and I'm not there like go all-in on
something at the start I like the test
and tweak and try and so the news let it
was the first thing and then the video
became the second thing they're like you
know this is working I'm gonna do this
crazy thing and brain my whole business
around believe and that's when
everything really started to take off if
you look at from an influencer point of
view that's when I started getting a lot
more traction more views more comments
more requests to do interviews and media
and partnerships and all that stuff
started to take off because I had built
an audience up and people really
understood my message for the first time
and what are you so for those listening
out there that may not have built
influence or might not even know that
they've already built influence had it
how does one know that they're building
influence like what are the what are
some of the key factors that you know
hey I'm actually building influence now
and then to had what what would be your
top three tips for someone looking to
build influence based on your experience
yeah I think the ability to influence
somebody really comes down to do you
have expertise in something that I'm
that I need and do I trust that you have
that expertise I think those those two
factors are really important at the
start so you might listen to me around
confidence issues or around
entrepreneurship or around a whole bunch
of other things
if you want to learn how to fix your
sink I'm not the guy to go to you know I
know zero I'm the least handy person
maybe in the world
I know zero and so my opinion counts for
negative whatever I tell you to do is
like do the opposite because I don't
have I don't have a track record of
success there and and you don't trust my
message there and so I think breaking
that down it's exciting because now
everybody has the ability to be an
influencer in something you're good at
something you have skills that's
something that most people don't have
whether it's fixing sinks or
entrepreneurship or piano or speaking or
writing books or whatever it is you're
really good at something and an easy
place to start is even thinking what do
people come and ask you for help on you
know look at your look at your email box
or your phone and like what are people
asking you to come help them do fix
their computer or make them a recipe or
whatever because you already have some
influence now it's taking that and maybe
you're not only influencing the 10
people in your circle and how do you
explode that out by being an even
greater actually thousands right by the
oh yeah yeah right like you may know
more about computers and your mom and so
she's helped but she's asking for help
on computers you know if your friends
were asking for help too great now how
do you take that and be one of the best
in the world around computers and just
your ability to have the domain
expertise and the trust and credibility
the more you have both of those then the
more people will want to follow you
absolutely and I guess on a side note
you know I see a lot of people you know
who are just starting off call
themselves so-called experts and you
know after six months I think they've
built influence so my question to you is
like we can if I was to use someone for
their particular service we can weave
the cowboys and the Sharks out very very
quickly because we built the sort of
experience to be able to tell whether
someone is an influential person or if
someone has just gone out there and I
see a lot of entrepreneurs
you know when you do the research when
you look deep down inside they've built
nothing and all they're trying to sell
is an online program with no harder no
mission behind it and they want to make
money online without working any hours
or any minutes at all a week and that's
what they're preaching out in the market
so how do we how does one let's say if
you are giving advice to someone who's
looking to get an influencer - for a
particular area of their business or
hire that person or engaging their
service how do you identify what is an
influencer what are the key factors what
was the expression used cowboys and
sharks is that what you said Cowboys and
sharks that's they must be an Australian
thing I've never heard of that I like
that you have the Cowboys and sharks
it's an Aussie thing for cowboys always
you know disrupting but in a bad way
yeah and you know no one wants to be
involved with sharks so very dangerous
waters yeah interesting I like it I like
I like it
so how you're asking if I went
entrepreneur if I'm running a business
or I'm trying to hire an influencer or
how do I know that's the right person to
go with what are the factors to consider
yeah and he might not be the influence
of themselves he might be a service that
they're providing but they're leading
out from the front saying yeah like
basically we're an influencer this is
where an expert in this field etc yeah
so I like to start consuming stuff on a
small scale to see how I feel about it
and then move on so if I'm looking at a
potential influencer and saying hey is
this this is person know what they're
doing know what they're talking about do
I want to give my trust to that person
are they are they are they worthy of my
trust and me now potentially spending
dollars and more time and like referring
my mom to follow this person to like do
I want to make that decision or not I
start consuming them in doses so if you
have a youtube channel I'm gonna start
watching your videos and see do I
resonate with them do they make sense
did you you know if I watch if I watch
an interview with with you Alex and your
give me some LinkedIn tips okay here's
this guy I never heard of him Alex okay
is giving LinkedIn
okay let me try that let me try one of
his tips out oh it worked
uh-oh worked okay cool what Alex is it
you who's this Alex guy I want to I want
to learn more about this gun then I
start digesting more of your stuff right
and now I'm following your podcast and
following your channels and following
what you tweet about so I'm looking for
something that I can pull out as a small
test to see doesn't work did it provide
value to me did it resonate with me
somehow and if it doesn't then then I'm
moving on but if it does and I'm gonna
want to go deeper with you and I think
that's where you get the ability to sell
right like too many people I think sell
too early you're selling your ebook or
mastermind or whatever before you build
the relationship apparently if alex is
now additional all sorts of great value
on his podcast and Twitter and LinkedIn
and all this great stuff sharing
knowledge has impacted me and I'm
thinking man I love what I'll just give
it away for free and now he has this
paid program that's gonna give me access
where I can ask questions to Alex
one-on-one or in a group setting know
what like he's already helped me a lot
I'm valuing it like it's not even it's a
no-brainer or I'm just gonna say yes
right exactly and I think another big
thing for me you know as you mentioning
that is obviously building a very
powerful online footprint like when I
google your name
you know first five to six pages of
Google it's just articles podcasts you
know publications you've been featured
in and you know in the online world
there's this thing we call the moment of
truth so TMO - the moment of truth where
you research someone and you're not it's
the beauty of the online space now is
that you you're no longer what you say
you are
it's what Google says you are and so if
I google your name and then you're
telling me that you're an expert in HR
but then I can see articles of you you
know plumbing and running a plumbing
business six months earlier then I'm
going to rethink about whether you're
all of a sudden became a HR expert
within six months so I always say Google
people go to fourth pages deep don't
just
look on the first page because some of
these some of the people that I know
that I you know I won't bring up their
names because they're just not the best
operators but they basically SEO they
name and so all that great links will
come up first and then the second and
third pages or other bad links so always
do your research and ask yourself like
Evan said does the content make sense
and if I implement the content and look
for those small wins in order to then
develop that that trust so what was it
that's let's move on now so what was the
biggest obstacle for you in building
your influence as you were trying to get
traction because a lot of people
listening on this show are probably
trying to build the influence they're
looking for ways to really build their
thought leadership and a lot of people
think at an early stage that it's a lot
of content I don't think it's a lot of
content I think it's strategizing and
the right content and the right amount
of content per month based on where you
are in your business like if you're a
startup writing five articles a month
probably is not the right right deal
because you got to get in front of
people and you got to share your message
in front of him now that's my belief
what's your belief around you know one
how much content to share but two or was
the biggest obstacle in you building
your influence the biggest obstacle that
for me in building my influence was me
believing that I was worthy other
but can get much more than like how many
videos I made or specific like yes you
need the strategies and attacks and all
that stuff super important and we can
dive into the details on that too of
what I did specifically but it wasn't
until a and believed that was worthy of
like Who am I to speak to this person I
had never met and I heard I have one
sentence of context and then give advice
and that absolutely back for a long time
and in my earlier you could track my
youtube career the videos are still up
you can
go back to my first one however many
years ago six seven years ago a lot of
the message that I have hasn't changed
but still I still talk about the same
things I was talking about back then as
I've grown like some things might be a
little different but the main principles
are all the same I'm much more confident
now I believe in myself more there's a
lot more conviction in the answers and
as I started to gain confidence in more
self-belief my influence started to grow
yeah regardless of if I had one video or
five videos it was me it was a product
that made the single biggest difference
how does a whole bunch of tactics and
things underneath there but for people
listening they're trying to be an
influencer and they may like thinking
like I can influence one person great
like I can influence that customer who
came in and and he'll listen to my
message 100 percent going from that to
thinking I can influence a thousand
people or ten thousand me four million
people like that you your message is
that worthy that's that's a that's a
mind trick man that that that twist not
out yeah I remember I meant like for me
even that even the goal of helping a
billion entrepreneurs like believe me
that I can actually do that believing
that I could have such a force on this
market that I could have that bigger
reach at the start that wasn't my goal
because I would have never thought that
I was capable of doing that and that was
my own limitation and what was what was
some of the things that helped you build
your confidence like whether certain
things you did that helped you build
your confidence was it someone you know
someone close to you maybe a family
maybe a friend said to you that started
this ripple effect what were some of the
things that built your confidence
the first step that was really crucial
for me was just understanding that it
existed these limiting beliefs that you
have are usually so just they're just
trapped in your subconscious so just you
just do it every day naturally you don't
even think about it it just is who you
are and so unless somebody or you find a
way to shine a light
say wait you I think what I'm doing here
is actually really holding me back and
you're never gonna change so for me one
of the things that really helped me back
in the earlier days of this part of my
adventure was I really have a need to
make people feel like I gave them value
I hate the waste in somebody's time like
coming on your show here
I respect the invitation if you felt
like I was not giving you value on this
podcast your listeners I would I would
like hate myself right and that's a good
thing and that it encourages you to you
know push forward and give a lot of
value and over-deliver and I'm always
early for meetings and all of that stuff
but the negative side was that I
wouldn't say yes to things because I was
afraid that I couldn't deliver the value
or I would say yes to something and
secretly hoped that they would cancel on
me well the day before so like something
as big as I got invited to go speak in
Brunei in front of the prince and all
that they're like national TV cameras
and a thousand people and I'm you know
when it's like three months out like oh
hey no problem and then like a couple
days before you're about to fly out and
panicking I'm kinda hoping that they
cancel on me so that may be
understandable and like that kind of big
scale but down to a micro level of a
start-up entrepreneur who wants to meet
over coffee to talk about her business I
would still secretly hope that she would
cancel on me even though I know I can
help her like I've done this a million
times
I'm way further along the path than she
is I'm gonna be able to give her value
and I'm still secretly hoping that she's
gonna cancel and then after the meeting
I'm always like that was so great right
like I helped another entrepreneur I
feel so good
they're like purest joy that I felt in
my life I was almost not doing because I
wish that they canceled on me and I
wouldn't go so far to cancel on somebody
else but I would have helped wouldn't
they would cancel on me and that was a
big like I just had to what what
happened for me was I noticed that I
would notice it later on the day and I
think is what you do
it's the Monday Morning Quarterback I
don't yeah and that expression is that
yeah okay Monday morning coral eyes back
on what did what you did wrong the day
before I think that's what you have to
do like once you identify this limiting
belief you realize it later like I
should have said that why didn't I just
say that instead of this I was too
scared or whatever and you don't realize
it at the moment but you realize it the
next day and then the more you realize
that the next day you get it closer and
closer and closer so now you're
realizing it that afternoon and then you
realize in it like 10 minutes after the
conversation and then you get to the
point where you realize it in the moment
like it's happening right now like I
like the myth right now I realize I'm a
brother screw it up right and then
having the courage to realize that it's
happening right now and I'm gonna make
the switch and and once you do that you
get used to that then you release the
limiting belief and that was one of the
biggest ones for me the thing that I
love doing most of helping entrepreneurs
I was holding myself back subconsciously
and releasing that really did it did a
big deal for me and also in terms of
building my influence right absolutely
yeah and I think you know when I I I
always say that if you if your Y is big
enough you know you'll conquer anything
you'll go through hell and back and I
wrote an article and I've created this
process called the inclination point so
anytime you any time you start a new
business
or you want to achieve a particular goal
you write the goal down and then you ask
yourself the question why is it an
absolute must to achieve this goal and
then you've got to write 45 reasons why
you want to achieve that goal now if you
can't write 45 reasons like that you
don't want it you don't want it bad
enough like touchwood if my mom was
going to hospital and they said Alex the
only way you could get to hospital and
save her life is to write 45 reasons I
think we could all you know come up with
450 reasons and I could do it within 30
minutes I'd have a saw hand but I'll
could do it so I've developed this
process and basically if you can't write
45 reasons then you shouldn't be doing
it plus when you write the reasons
you actually uncover the exact motives
on why you want to achieve this mission
so when you're going through the hard
times you actually look like this is
what I do I've ridden 85 reasons why I
want length on Sur to be the world's
best company when it comes to LinkedIn
training when I have hard times because
let's face it I'm not a robot we all
have hard times it's a roller coaster I
look back at those and it helps me move
through and then there are times where
there's you know you might get a little
bit arrogant because things are going so
well and you know business is
skyrocketing that actually humbles you
as well so I'd highly recommend you know
if you haven't read that article it's
called the inclination point it's on my
Huffington Post that column definitely
read it I going back to what you said
earlier as well I think it's it's a
final fascinating that you have it you
have the same belief around you know
value in people's time and I think a lot
of people just don't do that
I actually get up in my the the first
thing I say whenever I present I say
this our presentation will be the most
impactful presentation this year within
your business if it's not I want you to
talk to me and tell me why and then I
start off with that so we're obviously
thinking on the same same wavelength
there and so which kind of leads me to
so obviously having belief is important
you know you've taken certain steps take
take me through some of those strategies
that help you build your influence what
were some of the key drivers yeah I got
it so I think it's super important for
people who want to build influence to
figure out what method is gonna be best
for them because there's so many
different ways you can do it now there's
so many different platforms that you can
beyond that if you try to do all of them
you're gonna you're gonna suck at all of
them and not have success yet we're
thinking it's the stress for a lot of
especially entrepreneurs they feel like
you got to be on every social media site
you got to be creating content
everywhere oh and by the way you got to
run your business too and it just
becomes overwhelming and they don't do
anything and so all they are they hide
behind content
sure as well yeah yeah so I'll be
looking at which which platform best
suits you your style my my preference is
video I like video I'd rather be on
video than I would be writing something
or taking pictures and so that that
obviously leads me down a YouTube path
right but I could have if I loved
writing I could have had the same
success being a columnist the same
influence being a columnist or if I
could do really short messages I could
have great influence on Twitter and be
out there so I think it's first figuring
out what you're really good at and where
you want to get better at where you want
to really learn and develop and grow me
being a visual learner was naturally go
to videos
I think I'm lined up with where your
audience is so you don't necessarily
need to be a big name to carry a lot of
influence right like you might only want
to influence this small section of
people right if you could influence all
the people who are world leaders and be
an executive coach for world leaders you
don't need to have a mass market
influence you don't necessarily need to
have a youtube show you just need to
figure out how do I gain influence of
those hundred people in the world right
and so for whatever market you're at and
that could be insanely powerful
important so for me I wanted to reach
quantity I wanted to have mass reach but
you know it's not the right thing to do
it's just the right thing for me so
don't freak out and feel like you have
to have you know massive you to show or
massive LinkedIn presence or whatever
right you could crush it on just on
LinkedIn and be part of one specific
niche and just be the person to go to
and make a crazy career and have a lot
of influence and a big impact on the
world just by being the best at that one
thing so basically you're saying three
things figure out what you want to do
which platform best suits you and then
does that platform suit the target
market 100% absolutely awesome and what
what are the some small steps let's say
someone sitting watching this video and
hearing this podcast what a
would be three steps that you would take
to right now or today or this week that
would help build the influence so once
you've decided the network that you want
to be on where you want to establish
your influence the next thing let's
start looking at is okay how do I get
started it's great to plan but like you
got to do something gets do something
like get started taking action and and
expect it to suck and this is where
people fall down a lot because like
somebody listened to your show as an
example right okay alex is a great host
and you know you ask great questions and
I guess he's great guest and I listen to
it and I go home and I want to take you
know immediate action on stuff and
people may they know what a good podcast
now sounds like and then they go out
they try to make their own and they're
gonna fail at it right like hi you were
just making mistakes and stumbling and
nervous and you know and it's not the
gear and it's not the you know sound
effects and all that it's just like you
will suck at the start of anything you
know what is good and then you know that
you can't make that yet and so that's
where a lot of people quit they see this
great podcast and then they say well I'm
never gonna be like Alex or I'm never
gonna be like whoever it's like well
alex has been doing this for a while
then you know I've been making I have
3000 plus videos don't expect to be at
my level when you're first starting out
your first video will suck fine great
absolutely do it again tomorrow another
day right the quantity leads to the
quality and and you know what I always
even say to go it like let's say someone
wants to crush it on YouTube I would
tell them go and look at Evan
Carmichael's first video and then go and
look at the quality of the videos he's
got now and then understand that there
is a path to success and that is
continuous improvement like you say it's
the only time you see success before you
know sorry the only time you see what
did I say what's that saying of Jesus
forgave it we'll come back to it anyway
doesn't matter pick it up and we'll call
it an australian saying
ozzie thing sharks yeah yeah um sorry so
you yeah I mean I did a video on this
not so long ago on my channel it said
one of my seven ways videos I think
seven ways to have unshakeable self
belief and I started the video with bio
then showing me three years ago 2013 and
then what people are used to now and
just in the span of three years you see
such a big difference in this guy who's
on camera and that's not that long a
time in terms of time periods but it's
also thousands of videos and so you put
in the work and you'll see the
difference and if you use my stories and
examples great but you like any any
youtuber you go back and look at their
first videos and they're gonna suck but
by putting in the work and the hustle
and the grind slowly your tastes catch
up so like so your abilities catch up to
your tastes like your your ability to
create something amazing will now match
with what you think is amazing from
other people but it takes a while to get
there absolutely and I think it's that
it's also the mindset of wanting to be
the best like I always say that the
biggest competitor is yourself and I I
want to actually be the best I can be as
an entrepreneur so I understand that
even now I'm probably 5% of what I want
to be so it's always that gradual
improvement and nothing is perfect
overnight you're just got to keep
working at it what would be so in terms
of working at it what are some of the
biggest mistakes you've made let's say
top three that you would you know yeah
what are those top three mistakes and
what are the lessons learnt within those
mistakes that other people can learn
from so obviously they don't maker
themselves it's interesting I know that
I've been asked that I don't know that I
reflect much about mistakes just kind of
like keep going forward on them I think
so in terms of building in or what are
we why don't we reframe it in slogans
like I want to I like the challenge I
like this
and and specifically about building like
a community and building influence so if
I'm looking at what I do I think number
one just making excuses you know I can't
be on YouTube because I don't have the
gear I don't have the right camera I
don't have you know I'm not an editor
I'm not you know whatever then sure I've
got an accent you know all of the
excuses and it's just fear it's just for
you're just another limiting belief but
one that I initially recognized early on
like I can't do it myself so I need
somebody with me I think fear holds
people back and and the solution I think
that I just find a smaller way to do it
and and release the expectation of just
like expected to be crap great like just
keep going to another one I think I
think lack of consistency in the early
days was another problem that held me
back you know I might do a video a week
and then and then wait three weeks and
then do then do another video and then
back to video a week and then wait two
months and then that might have been
like a 10 month stretch of no videos or
you know I think that was my longest
something in there so I wasn't
consistent you know and like you're not
seeing the results fast enough and you
know that I think not being so attached
to the like enjoying the process more
not being so attached used to the goal
being addicted to the views and
subscribers and you know the the numbers
but like enjoying the work when I
started enjoying the work more I got
more consistent and by being more
consistent I also got better if the
person you become not not there in the
process not the end outcome that's most
important because someone who's you know
felt for businesses and built that
character is a lot more powerful than
someone who has never started so you
know because then they've got the
pedigree and they've got the character
to be able to launch something new even
though they would have lost all their
money they've still got that character
that they've built up would you agree
yeah yeah it was like you have to figure
out your style you're so nervous on the
front I remember in making some of my
first videos I used to I used a DSLR
camera that I had and it wouldn't
autofocus so I had to have my sister or
someone on my team come in and focus and
then leave the room because I couldn't
do a video with somebody there because
I'd be afraid of them like they're gonna
judge me I'm nervous I'm already nervous
enough looking at the camera so that
then they'd have to leave the room and
then every time I didn't have to do that
okay I'm gonna stand on the spot you
come in okay focus great okay leave
close the door okay hi guys
you know and then start talking other
crutches too like I used to always have
to go to the coffee shop and get a big
coffee I felt like I needed the external
juice I'll get me fired up right to
bring the energy like I couldn't do it
on my own I need that I need the
caffeine or whatever like that sugar
help me get excited and looking back in
those videos I'm not actually that
excited but I felt at the time that I
needed it I guess yeah but it's just
part of the process I think I think just
being consistent and not putting so much
pressure on it being great nobody told
me that it didn't have to be good you
know and that it's just part of the
learning process because I would look up
to Tony Robbins or Les Brown or like man
look at these guys look at how great
they are speaking and look at look at me
man I'm sucking over here and you start
to feel depressed but then like nobody
at home okay and how did you how did you
become more consistent what was some of
the things you put in place was that a
mind shift was it certain things you did
that form the habit it's a great
question I have to think back because we
did I did a whole bunch of Buddhism and
I stopped for like a 10 month period I
did one on Walt Disney that was my last
video for a long time and then why did I
pick it back up
I don't know you can that you're making
me do I'm gonna I'm gonna dream on this
now like Alex's keep me up at night with
his questions I try to figure out why I
got step back started in I think I think
the start gained was just answering
questions I think it was just I was
getting questions from people on emails
and I would write to everybody back on
email but it would take like you know 20
30 40 minutes on an email that was
in-depth and when you get one a day it's
fine but when you're getting you know
tons a day now it becomes like I can't
get back to people so I thought you know
what I'll just turn these into videos
and started doing video replies to
people and I think I think it was just a
release of the pressure I think it was
just you know what like this isn't
designed to go out and reach a million
people I'm just answering the question
for Jim and Jim will see it and maybe
some other people will see it and so I'm
okay if it doesn't it was not amazing
and so absolutely kind of expecting the
suck and releasing that pressure like
being yes wanted to be great but also
not putting so much pressure that it
makes me quit it it's one of those
things like I always say you know do
whatever it takes to achieve your goal
but we be happy regardless of the
outcome hmm so a lot of people go into a
sales go and they go they attach all
these emotions that if to it if they get
it and if they don't so for instance if
the guy doesn't buy from me or if she
doesn't you know enroll in our program
I'm gonna be disappointed or they're
gonna be ecstatic
I just think okay so if that person
signs up with you then they're part of
your mission so if they don't then
they're not part of the mission and
therefore it's okay like I'm still I'm
alive I'm not dead I can just and I live
by this model some will some won't so
what someone's waiting someone is always
waiting to hear your message that person
is not you know it doesn't reflect or
love what you have to say who cares move
on like someone's waiting so anyway
there's a bit of a rant
I like the Alex rant and when you think
of the word we're going to the Quickfire
and this is the last question okay when
you think of the would influence what's
the first thing that comes to mind when
I think of the word influence what's the
first thing that comes to mind I just I
did for some reason I just think
religion for some reason I don't know
where that's coming from but I guess it
is like you know you go and you're
preaching yeah well like you go in
whatever religion you are you go to you
go to your church or church equivalent
and you're there to hear the gospel or
the message that's supposed to influence
you to go out and do something so I
guess we should all be creating their
own religions of our values so I don't
know it's random but yeah there you go
at first here on the influences podcast
yeah all right so we're gonna enter the
quick fire round less than a minute to
answer five questions are you ready do
it alright what's the best book you've
ever read radicals and visionaries
radicals and visionaries who's that
who's that boy fabious wander oh it's
out of print you can try it's out of
print I'm sure you probably file for our
work week is my 1b okay done what's
what's at the top of your bucket list
what I'm doing right now all right
Olsson what's the best productivity app
you have ever used and why I don't use
productivity apps you're just productive
oh yeah I don't know I can be more
productive I just don't use productivity
apps all right so who's your who was
your auto growing up and why ah earliest
growing up or my parents are on the wall
behind me they taught me believe believe
is them my mom's last name is Castilian
my dad's is Carmichael and they taught
me I'm a ghost Ricky Carmichael and I
can do anything that I want it okay nice
the one sentence quotes or moment that's
made the most impact in your life and
why one sentence quote or a moment
loving these questions nothing comes to
mind immediately so I don't know this
but I have a lot but like one that comes
immediately to mind could it be the one
word belief
I think of Calvin Coolidge like he's
behind me on my desk and he says
persistence alone is omnipotent where
like it doesn't matter how smart you are
how genius who are in which town you
have it's just about persistence grind
grind grind grind grind so persistence
alone is Omni its persistence alone as
omnipotent is a is a all-powerful ish
way of saying something but if you read
the whole thing it it's impactful there
you go very very profound and what there
was one piece of advice you could give
your younger self what would that be
you're Evan Carmichael you can do
anything you want nice nice and I guess
we got we're gonna we're gonna end the
show soon but if there was like I always
say don't like I would never ever go to
a seminar I would never ever go to a
networking function read an article
watch a video unless I'm gonna do one
like it might even just be one small
thing that I learned that I go and then
implement and I think a lot of people
absorb content for the sake of feeling
that they're growing but really content
with that action to me is worthless I
don't actually would rather know less if
I'm not going to act on it so what's
your one piece of advice that you would
give to people around absorbing content
just try to take something that's been
said and find the smallest way to do it
today I think it's easy to get lost and
and you know listen to Alex's show I'm
sure you have like all these big ideas
these big campaigns
like we're gonna go on LinkedIn and have
this amazing content strategy and build
our influence and you build this grand
playing out and then like okay tomorrow
I started my plane and then and then you
don't do anything either so it's like
never lose sight of of a goal or the the
creation of a goal without taking some
kind of action towards achieving that
goal so as soon as you set a goal that's
not enough some tiny small action
towards achieving that goal if it's an
email if it's a phone call a bit setting
the meeting just if it's setting up your
LinkedIn account like whatever it is
anytime you set a goal in your life do
something one small step immediately to
get a little bit closer yeah absolutely
and it's it's momentum right it's what
like I don't know what it is about
momentum but like strange things happen
when you're when you're in flow and I
wish you could you know there was a
formula where you could go okay and that
probably is and that's execution because
execution to me builds flow want and
they'll be adversity within that
execution period but I just think you
know if you're why omission is big
enough like yours like 1 billion people
that's a big big mission and that's
exciting like I'm not even you know my
mission isn't 1 billion but that excites
me even listening to another
entrepreneur or seeing another
entrepreneuring to make that sort of
impact in the world and I think that's
what what excited me about having you on
the show and I think that's what a lot
of people are missing
I find a lot of people are in business
just to sell and make money and that's
one of the reasons why a lot of
entrepreneurs are now failing because
they have this expectation around
generating revenue rather than saying
like you are Evan how do I impact 1
billion people and then obviously you're
smart enough to know ok in return you
know I'm going to monetize this certain
ways to be able to build the life I want
and so what would be the advice you have
for entrepreneurs before we conclude the
the podcast and their-their show here
today sure are big decisions with the
heart small
with the head any the big decisions that
you want to make in your life the big
decisions well you know who you're gonna
marry where you gonna live what business
you're gonna start your career path
anything that's really big you make with
your heart where most people do the
opposite and they make it with their
head and so the head only understands a
world that currently exists because it's
logical right that's what the head does
you look at what's around you said this
is what's possible where the heart can
create something that has never been
created before and especially for the
entrepreneurs and visionaries who are
listening to this podcast if you want to
go out and do something big that's never
been done before the logical thing is
that it's not possible because it's
never been done that's the whole point
right and so all the people around you
and the voice inside your head the head
is saying don't do it so big decisions
with the heart and then use your head as
the practical side to help you figure
out the steps on how to go and do it
that's probably the most impactful
statement I've heard on our podcasts say
that again for us and please write it
down now get a tattoo have it front and
center it might be a post-it note might
be up on your wall give it to us again
and please write this down and remember
this always every day
episode 7 guys big decisions with the
heart small decisions with the head
there you go alright so thanks for
joining us on the show and obviously
having me as part of your show at the
same time if you guys want to find out
more about Evan you can go to his
website which is Evan Carmichael calm it
will be in the show notes as well the
articles on the way and the content on
there is phenomenal you know this this
guy's dedicated his life to helping you
become the best you can be and I think
anytime you get the opportunity to
engage with the person like that is is a
privilege and not a given right so I
definitely be going to the website
checking out the articles and getting
involved in the mission and obviously
connecting with them and watch
some of these YouTube videos because
they're phenomenal as well so really
appreciate your time and it was great to
have you on the podcast thanks for the
love man I appreciate it anytime
cool man that was really good
and then so yeah you know for my
audience here what time is it for you I
keep forgetting like it's like 5:00 in
the morning there's something for you
they're not
we started at 7:00 oh is it 7:00 okay
it's not that bad then yeah yeah okay I
thought it was like a crazy early whole
daylight saving everything good ah man
I'm that this you did well man 7:00 in
the morning I would be that that'd be a
rough start for me so you did well now
for people watching like where where are
the like when is this show coming out on
your podcast what's more details there I
think we banked up for November with the
other two podcasts so I think this one
would be coming out in December and we'd
probably put it like first the second
week of December because then we head
into like Christmas and no one is really
I think people are just starting to tune
out so this will probably be first or
second week of December we won't be
tuning out but people will all right do
they I'm I'm I'm doing five to nine
videos a day all through December bro
yes influential podcast where they going
is it linked is it to the link flew
answer or they just went to the iTunes
or yeah they go into iTunes and then it
will also so basically how will promote
this podcast is we'll send it to it
we'll put it up on our blog yeah which
is blog post or calm they'll then send
an email to a subscriber list we've got
over 18,000 they'll go on here it there
we'll also have it on iTunes
there'll be show notes and everything
that will create so we'll send you the
link as well for you to be able to share
it too cool well thank you Alex for the
opportunity thank you guys so much for
joining and watching hope you have an
amazing close to the week continue to
believe and we'll see
see beautiful see you guys